[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
what a [__] flop
of course it is
Republicans told us there was going to
be multiple indictments this is going to
be groundbreaking
and it [__] the bid
again they [__] the bed you know I
expected this report to produce at least
at least 500 prosecutions
of democratic lawmakers including the
impeachment of Barack Obama and Hillary
Clinton
what the [__] are you people yammering
about this report says nothing that we
didn't already know number one it's John
Durham on gate number one so right there
right off the bat you have to actually
go oh it's not credible
he's he's looking at the Mueller report
okay remember this this is about Russian
collusion and the Trump campaigns
attempt to collude with Russia in the
2016 election this is the investigation
of the investigators remember
do you remember and and also this is
Durham who is supposed to be a special
counsel separate from Bill Bard the
Attorney General at the time during the
Trump Administration who in fact was
investigating in coordination with Bill
Barr right
and Merrick garland does the right thing
here and just releases this thing
unredacted just drops it [__] it just
let the people have this nonsense
Durham brought two prosecutions during
this entire investigation four [__]
years two prosecutions he lost both of
them personally in federal court against
a jury
and there's no there's no more
indictments folks that's it
that's it it's over now it's not
technically over and the reason why is
because
Republicans think that they're going to
make this into something
right just like the laptop [__] they
think they're gonna use this as a
political tool to advance their power
so what they're gonna do is bring John
Durham which I am all in favor for folks
John Durham should sit in front of a
congressional committee yes 100 full
stop should sit in front of a
congressional committee that way
Democrats can absolutely make fool a
fool and a John Durham and fools out of
the Republican party because that's
what's gonna happen
that that we're we are going to get
clips
and see this is the thing this is really
the thing do you think
do you think that average Americans even
know who the [__] John Durham is
go ask your co-workers
say do you know John durman's have you
heard the Durham report
dropped yesterday they're gonna be like
what the [__] are you talking about
they're not gonna have a God damn clue
the only people who are spinning this as
the Derma the Durham report is
groundbreaking is the people who are
gonna vote for Trump no matter what it's
the cult
that thinks this is some sort of [__]
earth-shattering document and it's not
it's not number one it's because it was
done at the direction of Donald Trump
and everything he touches turns to
liquid [__]
absolutely turns to liquid [__] when
Trump has his hands on it
so why why should anyone be surprised
that this is just a big fat nothing
Burger
it didn't tell us anything we didn't
already know
it didn't there's no indictments I mean
other than the two that he failed to
[__] bring to a guilty conviction
the two people he did indict exonerated
in court federal court
you can't make this [__] up but it's a q
Anon World folks we're just living in it
and yesterday the big the real big news
isn't the Durham report
it's this Rudy Giuliani story if you
want to know the honest truth that's the
big story yesterday the revelations that
we got yesterday is the Rudy Giuliani
story not just the weird creepy [__]
where he's hiring women and promising to
pay them a million bucks a year so that
he can [__] them and do whatever he
wants with him and call him call them
his daughter while he's performing sex
it's [__] weird it's weird stuff
these allegations of course Rudy
Giuliani is a drunk creep everyone knows
it they even reference the Borat movie
in the documents and last night I was on
a Twitter space and oh my God they were
pissed they were pissed that the Borat
film is in the court documents like why
wouldn't it be of course it is that's a
prime example of how Rudy acts around
young women when he gets drunk who he
thinks he's gonna have sex with
he tucks his shirt all the way in his
balls yeah okay yeah he was tucking in
his shirt get the [__] out of here
anyone has ever seen that video of him
laying back on the bed following his his
own genitals while he's touching the
girl in the room
who is pretending to be a foreign
journalist
after he's had a few two whiskey sours
or whatever the [__] he's drinking brand
I don't know what the [__] he's drinking
I don't know it ain't coffee
but the real Revelation here in this
Rudy Giuliani because I was in the
Twitter spaces last night and Lev Parnes
was in the space with me
and Leb Parnes basically said yeah Rudy
basically hires women and promises and
all kinds of [__] he puts he would put
Trump on speakerphone this is what this
is the lead Partners is where it's not
mine
last night in the space and I I'm not
doing direct quotes here but the basic
gist of it was is that Rudy Giuliani
would put Trump on speakerphone to
impress these women like what who the
[__] is impressed by that so that just
goes to show you that this [__] this
woman that's bringing these charges in
this lawsuit against Rue Giuliani is it
some kind of [__] Democratic
operative
supposedly according to Le Parnes
Rudy Giuliani would use Trump as a as an
impression to be impressed by
I want to ask any woman out there in the
audience would you be impressed
would you be impressed if someone's like
oh I could call Donald Trump
[__] out of here
that's the last person 99 of women would
want anyone to call on speakerphone
unless they were getting him to admit to
crimes so they could tape him apparently
she was taping them
I know this isn't the 90s anymore she
was recording them I say tape there's
tapes there's [__] tapes there's
always tapes with these [__]
and apparently according to Leb Barnes
again last night in the space Webb said
yes Rudy would record everything and he
would put Trump on [__] speakerphone
and record the conversation
these people think they're the good guys
folks and they're the Baddies
they thought they were doing service to
humanity by overturning elections by by
delving waist deep into [__] and
Corruption Leb Parnes has said it in the
spaces before he thought he was doing
the right thing until he woke up
and realized he was doing the wrong
thing
but the allegation in this lawsuit that
I think is most important that most
people were missing because a lot of
people want to concentrate on the
salacious things and how Rudy Giuliani
is a [__] perv but we all know that
why do you think he's good friends with
Trump do you think Rudy Giuliani and
state friends with Trump because Rudy's
not some kind of [__] scumbag how how
[__] scummy do you have to be to be
friends with Trump more than five
[__] minutes
guy piled around with Jeffrey Epstein
okay get it got it okay you're good
the the part of the allegations that I
think is most significant in the
political body right because we all know
Rudy's of again he's a [__] scumbag
he's a perv
we all know that it's not hard to know
that we're not we it's not hard to know
he's a Broken Man either he's a [__]
drunk and he continues to push the
pillow guys slippers on his podcast
to survive here and he promises women
all kinds of money that he can't [__]
pay him because he can't even [__]
conjure up enough money from Trump the
point is this
let me get to it
the allegation in this
lawsuit is that Rudy Giuliani and Trump
we're coming up with a scheme to sell
pardons for two million dollars
and they would split the two million
dollars 50 50.
that's what she alleges and she alleges
she has not only [__] recordings of
them saying this
but emails and in this Twitter space
last night
that I was in
Lev Parnes said that yes I heard them
talking about pardon pardons but Lev did
not say he did not go this far to say in
the space that he heard money being
talked about
yes pardons now in our great system in
our great Republic uh when you have a
pardon it is not illegal and I know it
sounds this way
I know it sounds illegal but it is not
illegal
for someone to Lobby the president and
get paid to Lobby the president for a
pardon an example of that is Roger Stone
if you remember Matt gantz's best friend
and child sex trafficker Joel Greenberg
down in Florida
was was paid Roger Stone To Go lobby for
him to get a pardon
and that's perfectly legal lobbying in
this country is perfectly legal and
there is no real money cap on how much
you can spend for someone to Lobby on
your behalf
and all it takes is that you have
relation that they have relationships
with lawmakers and it's not just on the
federal levels folks it's on the state
level too
There are rules and regulations but
pretty much it's the wild west when it
comes to paying money for people to go
Lobby politicians for you and yes it is
legal it doesn't sound like it but it is
legal for someone to take money to go
Lobby the president now my question is
and my question to United States
Attorney would be
is it legal
for the president of the United States
to expect to receive a million dollars
in a 2 million dollar 50 50 split scheme
for each pardon that he does hmm I
wonder and I I also wonder I also want
to ask questions like how much did Roger
Stone and Steve Bannon and Michael Flynn
pay for their pardons I don't know I
hell how am I supposed to know if they
were out there scheming two million
dollars a piece I would imagine I would
imagine maybe they paid something and I
would wonder where they got that money
to pay that money for the pardon if
that's the case I don't know Harlan
Hitler I mean it he likes to pay
people's debt apparently I don't know
I'm just I'm just I'm not making
accusations I'm just asking I'm just
asking questions shouldn't we be able to
ask questions in this country without
ramifications it we we should be able to
ask questions of these powerful people
without consequence
is that you recognize that it's been a
while since we've seen old Tucker huh
now Tucker's Irrelevant this [__] maybe
I'll keep bringing his voice back here
on the Tony Michaels podcast to show you
how that the right spends everything
but they're spinning this Rudy Giuliani
story oh man they want to make this into
a metoo thing I heard me too last night
in this space at least at least a half a
dozen times at least I'm like me too
where the [__] you people been what the
metoo movement
what the [__] is this 2015
come on man everyone's moved past the
metoo movement we know we know women
should be believed when they level
accusations women aren't making up [__]
just just to tear down someone come on
do you know how difficult it is to bring
a federal lawsuit against someone like
this do you know how hard e Gene Carroll
worked and how broke she was bringing
this lawsuit and she'll she's likely to
fight even more and spend even more
money just to see any kind of money from
Donald Trump and it probably won't even
make up for the money that she spent and
the defamation that she's incurred
so get the [__] out of here with that
[__] that me too oh it's just a woman
trying to get it Rudy Giuliani for what
Rudy's [__] broke man he's [__]
broke
just because this woman wants the
[__] truth
and once the truth out there and once
Rudy Giuliani to have to admit it in a
court to [__] say yes this is what
happened [__] out of here man with that
me too movement that it's a woman just
trying to do this or do that get the
[__] out of here I'm sick of hearing
that [__]
no one no one believes that Rudy
Giuliani number one is credible in
saying that this is false Rudy Giuliani
is the one who lost his law license
because he went around from court to
court and state legislators a state
legislator and he lied he [__] lied
we saw it when Rusty Bowers testified
before the house January 6 Select
Committee Rusty Bowers testified that
Rudy Giuliani said he had the evidence
and never would give it to him because
he didn't have it he's a [__] liar
and of course he's a liar they all have
to lie every [__] one of these Trump
shills have to lie they have to there's
no other option
so spare me the [__] about oh this
woman is incredible she's some kind of
democratic operative get the [__] out of
here
but what I want to know what I want to
know is who got money for pardons and
how much was it that's what I want to
know I mean we're going to get the rest
of the case because this this this the
person bringing this case she has tapes
she has [__] emails
she has call logs
she was apparently being supposed to be
paid a million dollars to be his
business development manager or some
[__] some people were like oh he she was
just a secretary uh-uh no no that ain't
true Leb Parnes also said in that space
that he would bring these women on to
his staff and he would give them access
to all the emails all the phone calls he
would make them he would make them
record and and record him his
conversations
that was the whole point
is to impress them to you know get their
pants off so he can pretend they're his
daughter or some weird ass [__] that she
claims I don't know that's some weird
[__] but it's Rudy are we supposed to be
surprised by the weird salacious stuff
no I don't think so he's a [__]
scumbag he's a weirdo you can see it in
the tape with the uh the Borat tape
where he sticks his hands and fondles
his General he's not tucking in his
shirt that ain't how you tuck in your
[__] shirt any guy who's ever wore
dress shirt knows you don't lay down on
the bed and tuck your tuck your dress
shirt into your into the bottom of your
ball sack okay it's not a thing it's not
how it works I'm just here to tell you
that that's not out you [__] tuck in
your shirt okay it's not how you do it
what you do is you stand up you unbutton
your pants you tuck it in the front you
tuck it in the back you do your sides
you fold the sides so it's not like
sticking out like a [__] circus tent
you fold it and then you [__] butt in
your pants that's how you [__] tuck
in your shirt you don't lay back on the
bed and fondle your dick okay it's not
how you do it but whatever you you you
lie to yourself manga you lie to
yourself about Rudy you lie to yourself
about Trump you you've already seen what
happens when you shield for this
[__] in the Manhattan D.A grand
jury case where they brought 34 [__]
felony charges you already found [__]
around and found out when you [__]
make excuses for these pieces of garbage
these sexual abusers in the E Gene
Carroll case and you just go la la la it
didn't happen it didn't happen boom
guilty [__]
just [__] around and find out what
happens when you attach yourself to Rudy
Giuliani and John Durham for that matter
because if you're if you're if you're
wondering
why why the Durham fell flat on its face
it's because it is Trump it's all fraud
it's all [__] it's all lies all of
it
watched MaGa on Twitter this morning
call for the impeachment of Barack Obama
they they want they want the Congress
oh my God think about this for a second
they're gonna impeach Barack Obama when
he's been out of office damn near as
long as he was in right this is like
this is like lefties wanting to impeach
George Bush for going into Afghanistan
and Iraq what I mean yeah sure I didn't
agree with those decisions we're really
gonna try to use our congress's time our
precious time and legislation
when we could be doing things like
making sure you don't go broke because
of a medical bill making sure that
education in this country not only is a
[__] hence a solid foundation because
Republicans are tearing it apart all
around the country in these [__]
States
but also fund fund education and make
sure
that it's affordable
I I don't know make make sure that
people have a decent [__] wage so
they don't have to have four [__]
jobs make sure we have decent
immigration policies so working migrants
can come to this country and make sure
that we don't have a stop in our food
chain in our food supply
you aren't going to see [__] lazy ass
real white people going and working at
these farm jobs [__] no
apparently the grocery stores in [__]
Florida are [__] empty
truckers won't even go to [__]
Florida
because it's such a [__] fascist
hellscape
this is real stuff that we could be
working on that our Congress should be
doing let alone the [__] debate about
the unconstitutional credit uh debt
ceiling the credit limit get the [__]
out of here that's unconstitutional 14th
Amendment clearly says it [__] that debt
ceiling here's what I think I think Joe
Biden should just come out and say 14th
[__] you you don't get to do anything
with the debt ceiling you can go [__]
yourselves
100 full stop you can go [__] yourselves
I'm not negotiating Kevin McCarthy's
standing in front of a microphone this
morning saying he's gonna cut your
benefits
he wants you to have a work requirement
person on Social Security who's [__]
retired what the [__] does retired mean
and we're gonna stand around [__]
debating these [__] moglodytes over
some stupid [__] Durham report that
tries to prove that Barack Obama should
go to gitmo get the [__] out of here
with this nonsense waste of [__] time
you moglodytes are dumber than dog [__]
and until you pluck your head in your
ass and realize you're being [__]
duped and you're being used to [__]
press the agenda of a bunch of fascist
[__] elitist in this country maybe
just maybe we'll get some stuff done
when you do that when you come to that
realization
Kevin McCarthy you [__] scumbag this
morning he was asked what programs all
of them he said all of them all of them
should have work requirements you heard
that right [__]
when you get 65 and you're on Social
Security you gotta go to work [__] to
get your Social Security when you're on
Social Security Disability because you
can't work tough [__] [__] go to work
they're they're making sure that we
ain't got migrant workers in this
country [__] migrant workers [__] the
writers [__] the writers [__] them too
[__] [__] Union laborers [__] them [__]
anyone who's in labor you're retired ass
you're you person who's receiving Social
Security or Medicare or any kind of
[__] state-funded assistance get your
ass to work
that's what they're saying and you
[__] are bitching and moaning
and complaining about some [__]
trumped-up Durham report that John
Durham and Bill Barr somehow wanted to
frame up get the [__] out of here
Americans are sick of your [__]
nonsense and you think you think you're
orange Mussolini Jesus Trump is gonna
beat Joe Biden you are some dumb sons of
[__]
you are some dumb [__] you
don't understand how Americans even feel
about this [__] you don't get it I go in
these spaces all the time and they want
to talk about they want to get in the
Weeds about the [__] facts and what's
the evidence and who's guilty and who
get the [__] out of here the Americans
don't have time for that [__]
Americans in this country don't have
time to [__] figure out if John
Durham is credible or not they don't
even give a [__] who John Durham is if
you want to know the God's honest truth
they really to be quite honest
Unfortunately they don't even give a
[__] that the Trump campaign did collude
with Russia to try to win the 2016
campaign they don't give a [__] they
don't care that all the way way back 20
over 20 years ago that Dick Cheney
wanted to go into Iraq for the [__]
oil they don't give a [__] people they
don't give a [__] they ain't got time to
give a [__]
they got 80 hours they gotta work
to pay for their [__] to put their kids
through school put [__] shoes on
their feet and clothes on their back
they gotta make sure they have expensive
ass health care so that way if they get
sick they don't go broke because of a
[__] medical bill
yeah they got they gotta survive under
the tough conditions of inflation
because corporate profits are higher
than ever and corporate greed is higher
than ever
and you think you think the majority of
Americans are going to give two shits
about some report that some special
counsel that was appointed by some
[__] pretend ass president because he
got his [__] ass hurt because he got
caught colluding with Russia
and he didn't want you to know that he
was cheating to win
any one on a technicality
[__] out of here with this nonsense
and you also want us to believe that
Rudy Giuliani isn't the scumbag that he
truly is isn't the Pervert that he truly
is and that corruption runs deep and
it's right there in front of your face
to see it
when Trump and Rudy were on the phone
apparently according to this allegation
they were trying to figure out a way to
make a million dollars a piece on each
pardon Trump was going to give
laughs
well [__] me running
[__] me running I'll tell you what I'll
tell you what folks do you know one
thing that people will pay attention to
if that's true if it's true that Donald
Trump was trying to make a million
dollars a pardon I guaran damn T you
we're gonna put that into the narrative
I guaran damn to you that's an easy
thing to get the American people to
believe they hate that [__]
already they know that motherfucker's
corrupt
and you don't think you don't think that
that little nugget that little nugget I
don't I really don't even give a [__] if
it's true or not
you don't think that the American people
will grab onto that and take a hold of
it
how do you think [__] political
narratives work how do you how do you
think this [__] works
they're never gonna know who John Durham
is they're never gonna know the
the intricacies of the collusion of
Russia
there is one thing they'll understand
they know what a pardon is they know
they know what a president is and they
know what money is
and they know they know that politicians
are corrupt and when they hear that Rudy
Giuliani and Donald Trump
was trying to sell [__] pardons to
people and they're gonna split the two
million dollar profits 50 50. that's
something that's something Miracle
that's an idea the American people can
can grab onto
so [__] them
[__] them they want to play this game
Let's Play it [__]
that's right we'll put I'm gonna put my
[__] gloves on I don't give a damn
I'm not gonna oh man there's there's no
evidence I don't care if there's no
evidence she's alleging this apparently
there's tapes so I want to hear the
recordings let's do it let's go to court
let's [__] do that [__] in the
meantime we're still going to talk about
how Rudy Giuliani and Donald Trump
apparently
allegedly we're selling pardons for two
million dollars a piece and I'm gonna
keep saying here on the Tony Michaels
podcast every single weekday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch don't forget to
subscribe right here on YouTube you're
not going to want to miss a single
[__] episode trust me they get better
and better yesterday we were talking
about uh the I hate boobs crowd
on Twitter over the weekend
God knows what we're gonna talk about
today we got Texas Paul on I'm sure he's
gonna have uh his opinion on what the
Durham report is and what it truly isn't
what a sack of [__] man this thing this
thing is such a flop it's not even I
mean really honestly I don't even know
why last week last week they're like
Hunter Biden's laptop
transactions we're gonna get indictments
nothing this week Durham report there's
no indictments
horrible horrible two weeks in a row
they flop I can't wait to see what their
flop is next week to be quite honest
with you but we got Texas Paul here
today you know it's Tuesday so we got
him here today to talk about it don't
forget to download every single episode
of the Tony Michaels podcast on Apple
Spotify Google do me a huge favor let's
get our downloads up over there even if
you don't regularly listen and download
Go download a couple episodes a week
take a listen to the first 15-20 minutes
see what you think on the audio version
send me some critiques tell me if the
audio version is as good as the video
version do that for me and give a review
while you're on your favorite directory
also if you're on Facebook you can watch
us over there at the Tony Michaels you
can watch it live or on replay on our
Facebook page at the Tony Michaels also
I want to thank everyone over on Twitch
we're getting major support on Twitch
major support more and more subscribers
every day more followers did you know
it's free it is free to follow us on
Twitch doesn't cost you a single nickel
you just download twitch get you an
account push follow and that's free now
if you're an Amazon Prime subscriber
there's a way for you to give us a
couple dollars of a Billionaire's money
I wish it was elon's money
but it's Amazon's money so it's Jeff
Bezos money it's his penis rocket money
but you know what whatever I'll take
I'll take the penis rocket money however
it'll come
no pun intended but here's how you do it
here's how you do it you link your
Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account that's right if you have an
Amazon Prime account you get one free
subscription with your Twitch account so
go to the 20 michaels.com there's a link
there that says link Amazon and twitch
click that link it'll show you all the
directions to link the two you give us
your one free subscription every single
month you have to renew it every month
you go in there you give us your one
free subscription and I get some of that
penis Bezos rocket money
it's a few dollars every month but it's
huge it's huge for us because the more
of you that do it the more money you
receive and honestly
um it I I can't tell you the great
support that the audience gives you're
the best audience in the world you truly
are you're here every single weekday and
today is Tuesday it's Taco Tuesday but
it's Texas Paul Tuesday so don't go
anywhere we're gonna have Texas Paul
talking about the Durham report right
after this break
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we have plenty of Slim Jims
skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again years
Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one in
your absence I discovered a rash on my
neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
yours Tammy
[Music]
[__] them [__] em [__] em [__] em [__]
em [__] em we're back to the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
it's Tuesday
I know Texas ball there's a damn good
chance there's a damn good chance but
he's gonna eat tacos but I bet I bet
he's not gonna eat the slim jim tacos
that we had on the show Texas oh welcome
welcome back it is Tuesday I'm glad to
have you my friend and you know what it
worked out perfect I was excited
yesterday when the Durham report dropped
on a Monday afternoon I was like some
[__] me and Texas Paul are going to
talk about how much [__]
is being said about the Durham report so
what's your what's your initial take on
the Durham report I'm interested
I have not seen
anyone it's a it's a very appropriate
you're talking about Rudy Giuliani
because I have not seen anyone since
Rudy Giuliani
take their reputation and their
professional life pour gasoline on it
burn it down to nothing but ashes and
then themselves go to those ashes Squat
and take a giant dump on it and then eat
it uh this this is I mean wow
I've been reading the highlights of it
it it's it's a fairly substantial report
I mean it's well I say that as far as
reports go it ain't much but it's still
a lot of reading because these reports
tend to be you know but I have to tell
you what I am seeing so far is trash I
mean I I just
I just the the whole process from
beginning to end is just really just
shocking because you know Durham had a
reputation as a mob prosecutor going
into this right well and I mean that was
one of the reasons why Bill Barr and
Trump went to Durham is because he had a
decent reputation but he was still
willing
um to shield for Trump you know that's
that's what I believe right because we
we even watched it because if no one's
aware the Durham John Durham was a
signed special counsel to investigate
the investigators and and all it is is a
special counsel to investigate the other
special counsel which we know is is
Robert Mueller's uh the Mueller special
Counsel on Russian collusion which by
the way Texas ball to give you I know I
know I don't usually drop data in facts
but to give you give you an idea of the
difference between the Mueller report
and the Durham report the Mueller report
had 37 criminal indictments 37 uh the
the Durham report didn't produce any in
the end it had two uh indictments that
Durham personally lost in court
um and it wasn't a mistrial hung jury it
was a not guilty it was an acquittal
verdict I mean he [__] lost big time
and then in this report he blames the
jury that he picked because he was there
hand picking the jury it's really weird
stuff that Maga is excited about this
Durham report it almost feels like last
week when they were excited about a few
transactions they found
um on the treasury website it really is
[__] weird stuff
yeah it feels exactly like that it
really does and and you can't overstate
what you just said there Tony about he
brought two prosecutors prosecutions to
court
um and he had one guy that actually pled
out uh another prosecution that pled out
didn't go to court but what he pled out
to was so nonstick nonsensically not
important it was just dumb but but
looking at the prosecutions Tony
look man you know Mrs Texas Paul is a
fat she's retired friend whoa whoa did
she go to Washington DC with uh her fed
Brothers the Patriot front because a lot
of people are saying
yeah no I mean she's actually legit
legitimate oh so you mean legitimate she
is
right she she has she has been involved
in some serious Federal prosecutions and
I will tell you this she will tell you
this if the feds take you to court and
prosecute you they don't miss
they have a prosecution uh rate well
over 90 percent I mean they've got
almost 100 prosecution rate they are
really [__] good at this Tony
and
for if you look at the Dan Chico
danchenko prosecution
pick up a defense Tony
he didn't call a single witness that
prosecution out of Durham's shop was
such a [__] show
that the jury took a look at it
and just said
no no
yeah the same universe is guilt and they
interviewed the the jurors afterwards
and and the jurors were like
I don't get it he gave us a list of five
things he had to prove
and then didn't prove them right and and
but Texas Paul that goes but that goes
to trumpism in general right like that's
the whole that's the whole stick of
trumpism in the first place is they tell
you all these all this [__] that they
think is is true and the reason why you
know it's the Democrats fault and it's
liberals fault and it's woke agenda and
blah blah blah yakety schmackity right
and then in the end when you question
them when you get right down to it they
ain't got to shred evidence that any of
that [__] is true and it's all 100
[__] and and it's just trumpism in
general right that that it's all just
nonsense and no one no one's gonna
believe it because it's just not based
in any kind of reality
yeah and I tell you they they picked
Durham for a reason prosecutors
um and this isn't a bad thing you know
they they have a you know it's like
muscle memory you prosecute the same
kind of case
and you get good at it you do you just
get good at it that's why they have such
high prosecution rates is that's how the
doj functions you get a prosecutor you
put them on a kind of case he works that
case he becomes an expert on that kind
of case durum was picked to do exactly
what he did right they knew his muscle
memory would be to go back and try to
tear into the FBI because if you
remember have you ever seen that movie
Black Mass Tony with Johnny Depp about
Whitey Bulger
a lot of people didn't watch it I want
to say that I have but I I I I might
have watched it but I I can't recall
good movie recommended for a lot of
people the prosecutor in the end that
takes down the corrupt FBI agent John
and this really happened in the real
world folks this movie's not a
documentary but it's it it it's good I
suggest you look the prosecutor in the
end that was the good guy that took down
John Connolly the corrupt corrupt FBI
agent that was Durham in real life that
was John Durham right so that is his
shtick that is his muscle memory is to
tear into the FBI into the doj and look
for this kind of stuff that's what they
wanted right so you know
well I I I want to I want to Pivot here
too and he failed miserably well
absolutely well I mean again it when
you're not because that's that's the
whole problem with trumpism in the doj
right like we've seen it and I'm gonna
pivot to Bill Barr here we've seen it
with Bill Barr with the Mueller report
where he had to put out a report
um basically
rebutting the port before they're
totally [__] redacted Mueller report
came out and the reason why is to
protect The Narrative of trump did
collude with Russia like he did he did
the campaign was colluding with Russia
that's how it worked listen this idea
because this is manga's idea this
morning online
the manga's idea is that Hillary Clinton
colluded with Russia so that she would
lose the election against Donald Trump
this is about as stupid this is about as
[__] dumb as thinking that antifa
dressed up as Trump supporters went to
the Capitol to stop the certification of
Joe Biden being president it's really
dumb [__] it makes no [__] sense on
his face like and that's why they have
to get into the weeds and spend these
stupid little details because the idea
doesn't even hold water like just the
simple idea doesn't even hold water but
the difference between the Trump doj
under Bill Barr and the Biden doj under
mayor Garland and I know a lot of
liberals hate Merrick Garland right now
because he he hasn't charged Donald
Trump which he's not in charge of the
Donald Trump investigation Jack Smith is
the actual special counsel in that case
but Merrick Garland didn't redact any of
this he didn't he doesn't he didn't
hesitate to to give some sort of [__]
rebuttal before like Bill Barr did to
try to spend the narrative Merrick
Garland read the report probably went
this is [__] well how much did we
spend on this and how much time went
into this we already knew all this [__]
and he just released it he just [__]
released it he didn't give it he didn't
give it any kind of fanfare he didn't
try to [__] try to manipulate it
politically he just released the [__]
report that's all he did and that's the
difference between a trump doj and a
regular doj is because the reason why is
because Trump Bill Barr John Durham and
anyone else in the Trump Administration
knew that Trump is corrupt they knew the
truth they know the truth they know the
[__] truth and they always had to
[__] do anything they could to try to
convince the country that what the truth
was was not actually the truth Jesus
Christ have you seen how much he's
posting on true social this morning oh
my God Grandpa is on fire this morning
and he's terrified that this Durham
report is going to fall flat just like
his [__] rally in Iowa fell flat over
the weekend I tell you what I can't tell
you how incredible it is Texas Paul that
Trump is taking all these losses and
Ronda Santa still is not in this race I
have I can't I don't even understand it
listen Ron DeSantis if you can hear my
[__] voice now is the time man dude
you're you're Governor weirdo you are
not going to help yourself at all if you
wait do it today get out front of a
microphone today and announce your run
for president you would not got a
[__] chance if you don't do it
because Trump is lost after loss after
loss he's a [__] loser and they're
still behind him Ron they're still
behind him you better get out and do it
sorry and and no man I I and I and I'll
tell you
um this actually I'm gonna make a
addiction here
the Republicans
mayor Garland just kicked the
Republicans in the balls with this
report they were counting on it being a
redacted report right they were because
they had all of these false narratives
this is what Republicans do they you
know like the other day I was telling
people I can't remember what we were
talking about but oh yeah they were
claiming oh yeah I've got secret
classified information right here I
can't tell you what it is but let me
tell you what it says you know what I
mean it it's it's [__] they were
really really really counting on this
report coming out with redactions so
that they could run and say that it said
a bunch of [__] that it does not say one
February Donald Trump the Cheeto dust Q
anoner even posted on true social saying
this is going to be the biggest
bombshell it's the biggest [__]
bombshell in the history of ever ever
there's going to be hundreds of
indictments not one indictment
with this report not one yeah and and
the two failed indictments that were
brought before this report dropped it's
just
and Tony I actually believe this is this
is going to end up doing just a mirror
opposite of what Republicans thought it
was going to do you know you're like
firemen that are fighting a fire a
forest fire they'll go through and
they'll torch a section they'll make a
flatline controlled burn
right and and the idea is that it burns
towards the fire it heats up the fuel
and then ends up stopping the fire right
every once in a while
it goes backwards they'll light these
you know Burns and it'll run backwards
and it actually makes things worse I
think that's what the Republicans are
facing right now is this report is so
damn bad
that we have to start questioning John
Durham
because I'll give you one quick example
the FBI agents when he was interviewing
them and their their investigation into
Crossfire hurricane which is what all
this stems from
um he said were you given this piece of
information and what it was was it was a
document that was classified at the time
and John Radcliffe went on to unclassify
it as part of this political operation
it was it was a rumor
it was a rumor it was rumored it was a
Russian rumor okay
so intelligence operatives looked at
this and said we're not going to give
this a lot of credit we're not going to
put a lot of faith in this this is just
a rumor we can't verify it nothing well
he takes it and presents it to these
agents and says when you were started
your investigation were you given this
rumor
to start a narrative that they weren't
given the whole story well you know the
the counterintelligence part of the FBI
had already looked at all this stuff
they had been briefed John the CIA had
been briefed
um President Obama had been briefed on
this well and and that's the Hillary
Clinton the intelligence agencies
collect all intelligence right rather
it's whether it's or not they have they
can't just go well let's look at these
two p7s does this feel real or does this
feel fake no they have to they have to
take everything in account and they have
to figure it out so yeah when they take
a piece of fake of fake information and
there's and the FBI or the CIA is
smoking it out yeah they're gonna smoke
it out to see if it's real or if it's
fake and yeah people are going to get
briefed on this stuff to see if it's
[__] real or fake people think they
determine it I think it's actually
nefarious I think Democrats are are
going to need to dig in on this because
these agents were told
that they that this was withheld from
them and then he took their reactions to
that
which wasn't true
took their reactions to the to that and
then wrote it up in the report to say
they were angry that they were upset
that they were not given all the
information out there which isn't true
this was a report the FBI already had
so John Radcliffe
president Trump's dni at the time right
takes this race performance he's a
former Congressman right right he highly
partisan guys [__] takes this unverified
report that's just a rumor just from
Russia
declassifies it puts it out to the press
and says it's true it's verified all
this other and the intelligence
community at the time went nuts they're
like none of what you just said is true
so they I am
seeing and looking at this that John
Durham set up a situation with these
agents to try to create this narrative
that this was something nefarious that
this was something bad and and you know
why you know what you know what the
report was over
Hillary Clinton
they're saying that this report was just
a rumor in Russia that said Hillary
Clinton was trying to divert divert
attention from her emails by by creating
the investigation all by itself
that was again to to say that Hillary
Clinton and all was was colluding with
Russia so that she could lose the
election this is really stupid [__] like
it's the dumbest and and again that's
the reason why they have to get in the
weeds and they have to do the weeds
thing and the reason why because on its
face
it's it's just doesn't hold water the
whole narrative doesn't hold water
um the other thing too that I want to
point out is that and a lot of people
are pointing this out on on Twitter is
that the dermaport really feels like the
2019 doj
um uh oig report of the Russia probe
um
the the and and it's just he just
basically [__] lifted everything from
that report and put it in his report and
that's why I say folks when someone gets
in your replies about the Durham report
it's it's not a Durham report it's the
same [__] we already know it there's
nothing new that is why one Merrick
Garland didn't redact a [__] single
word of it not a period did he react
redact excuse me
and he released it almost immediately
after reviewing it
without it being any change any reaction
he just [__] dropped it and the
reason why is because there's no new
information there's no new there's no
New Revelations in it none other than
now we know what John Durham's aim was
and that was the Run cover for Trump and
to try at all cost to have some sort of
[__] narrative like Texas Paul is
saying that Hillary Clinton was the one
that was colluding with Russia not Trump
that's it that's all it was that's all
the direction was and Tony you've you've
it can't be stressed enough that this
you're right he's trying to act like a a
an IG here and
that wasn't his job it wasn't his
mandate it wasn't what he was supposed
to be looking at right he he this this
is bad I mean this really looks
nefarious it looks bad he left his
entire mandate and went over here and
started running a political op
right well and it was not his job to
look at and and here's what I'll say is
it's Gabe Sanchez is joining us finally
geez Louise no I'm just kidding um
I got things to do in the morning here's
the thing I know I know you're gonna be
excited about this next thing I'm gonna
I'm gonna say about the Durham report
and then I want to move on to Rudy
kaluti Grandpa farty mcsharty Rudy
Giuliani because boy hell that's a
[__] that's a great story uh and I
love a great story and I love spinning
political narratives so we're gonna do
that today with the you don't even need
to spin it well no no
it's moving the whole thing so why you
want to talk about Rudy but here's the
thing
um one last thing on the Durham and we
can talk about it for a few minutes is
that Gabe we're gonna have clip after
clip and you're gonna probably have a
what was that on this specific hearing
where John Durham is gonna and this is
the best part this is like going to be
the crescendo on this [__] [__] show
that they've had for the past four years
that Durham was supposed to bring down
Clinton they were to take him down the
gitmo and Obama and hang them or
whatever the hell like you and honors
say here's the thing John Durham is
going to go before a house committee and
not only is he gonna make a fool of
himself but Democrats are going to ask
him real questions and make not only
John Durham look like a [__] fool but
they're gonna make the Republicans that
are asking him questions and are hailing
this report is some kind of Revelation
as all [__] fools and and that's what
the American people are actually going
to remember about the Durham report
because frankly No One's Gonna read the
[__] report they'll watch video
though of John Durham whoever that is
that's how they're going to react
whoever this fool is make an absolute
fool out of themselves in front of the
American people on camera so I'm excited
about that yeah yeah yeah well I'm
excited because again right uh
Republicans don't have the foresight to
Future proof and say hey maybe we
shouldn't do this because
the one thing I didn't really see uh
a lot of people talk about yesterday was
do you remember the report that came out
in January right there was an update
that happened in the end of January that
revealed that in 2019 Durham began
investigating the crimes of a probe into
these potential connections between
Russia and Trump and they found Trump
was the one committing crime exactly and
Bill Barr was part of that investigation
which exactly which absolutely shatters
up the whole special counsel structure
anyways when the Attorney General is
coordinating with the special counselves
the idea that we have reports of you
know Bill Barr and and Durham you know
having whiskey on a couch in the office
kind of [__] and like collusion
sounds like Rudy Giuliani stuff whiskey
maybe not as heavy of a drinker as Rudy
Giuliani but you know probably in the
same you know wheelhouse but the idea
that
that they're like yeah we should you
know Jim Jordan uh God the you know what
bless that idiot's heart because he
really thinks every time he's gonna own
the libs and what do we see
time and time and time again they
[__] face plant they step on a rake
right in the face and what we're gonna
find is they're gonna open the door
they're gonna open the [__] door wide
open thinking they kicked it down and be
like oh man we revealed we found this
stuff and it's like okay well let's talk
about Italy huh let's talk about the
crime that uh Trump was linked to and
that you worked with Bill Barr to not
really investigate it so let's talk
about that you know so the idea that
you know Jim Jordan and [__] James
Comer and every one of these other
Republicans think they're going to own
the lives through any of these wild
investigations whether it's the Durham
investigation it's the Biden
investigation you know they're gonna
keep trying to uh to defame certain
people under the guise of we have a
whistleblower we have an informant they
said it not us we're just repeating what
they said yeah yeah no we all know it's
[__] imaginary friends over there for
the Republican Party these people don't
exist but they're creating this facade
to protect themselves and I'm just
excited for when they do have that
hearing and Jim Jordan's gonna [__]
face plan hard because the Democrats are
like do you think it was literally this
year like do you think we have not
forgotten the last three and a half
months where the last update came that
revealed that was not so good for Trump
you guys sure you want to do this [__]
it fine you want to do it let's go ahead
yeah right well Texas Paul so so I I
want to say we shouldn't take the shovel
out of their hands while they're digging
their political grave because we really
shouldn't we should let them continue to
do this nonsense like this morning Kevin
McCarthy was talking about how he he's
not leaving any program off the table
for uh that have work requirements look
I'm like what the [__] are you [__]
me you mean retired people on Social
Security not gonna have to go to work to
get their social security but Texas Paul
let's stop getting those Weeds now what
I want you to talk about is the
possibility
and the absolute [__] show that is gonna
that is gonna happen when John Durham
sits before a committee and has to be
questioned by democrats like Daniel
Goldman
tell me tell me would tell me what
you're looking for when a professional a
professional questioner like Daniel
Goldman who is now a congressman is
going to be able to question John Durham
and just absolutely shred him
Durham guys like John Durham are used to
sitting in the captain's chair they are
not used to being questioned they aren't
and he is going to fall apart like
nothing you have ever seen he's going to
get angry he's going to get flustered
he's going to get frustrated because
they are going to literally slice and
dice him to pieces because his
investigation was such a complete
partisan [__] show and he's not going to
be able to defend it and and he is
literally you're going to see him John
Durham has this habit he's one of those
very light-skinned people that when they
get upset their cheeks get really ready
red hey hey you're going to see that all
over the place when I get pissed off I
get red as [__] I'm not gonna but that's
like an even wreck we're talking about
like you know like just like Rosy Cheeks
but it's like a weird
you know but and I'm telling you I'm
telling you guys
I really hope somebody like Dan Goldman
grabs this and runs you know you're
talking about don't get in their way
Tony you're absolutely right we need to
take this Durham report and we need to
run with it because I mean this is
really shitty stuff that him and Bill
bark hooked up
I mean you can look at this
investigation you can see very clearly
they're trying to build a narrative here
that isn't true right it's just not true
I've got a clip here um before we move
on to the Rudy colludi story because I I
really I really want to get to the um
the
he likes to have sex and call the person
he has sex with his daughter I don't
know what that's about but but I I it's
weird stuff yeah like the Democrats are
always being accused of this weird stuff
but it always seems like Trump people
and trumpers and Maga are the ones who
are I mean doing this though we
shouldn't I mean I don't know
Rudy Giuliani yeah is exactly the person
that we all thought he was like yeah
well of course I mean he wasn't hiding
it you know what what's funny
drinking you know we got to go back to
this because yesterday I ever get the
motherfucker's name in the space he
really was mad he was like oh people
like Tony come in this space to get
their sound bites I'm like this is an
audio broadcast man what the [__] else
is inside sound bites it's audio you
dumb [__] it's media it's me
talk I'm a commentator they invited me
in to say salacious [__] and you're mad
you're mad that I'm telling the truth
because you want to defend a guy who was
talking about how he likes to have sex
with this woman because he she reminds
him of his daughter that's not my
problem that's a you problem it's not a
man appreciate I know yeah Lord there
are tapes but the other thing is it
really goes you know kind of what we
were talking about yesterday Tony which
is the idea that these you know
there are there are uh Universal truths
in this world right yeah Nazis are bad
right right uh you know punching Nazi if
you definitely punch them if you can you
know groomers pedophiles uh sexual
predators they are bad right right now
people on the right Republicans want to
say things like you know Democrats are
the problem they're the groomers they're
the pedophiles they're we've got to save
the children but as soon as something
happens and we say yeah but as soon as
something happens we say hey that's
that's pretty bad those Nazis are bad
those fascists are bad those uh oh he's
Tony's talking about there's a space
that happens probably every day it's on
it's a Twitter space yeah the political
ones are at night yeah yeah it's Mario
what's what's Mario's last name I forget
a lot of people don't know what a
Twitter space is yeah yeah if you go if
you go to Twitter
um if you have a Twitter account if you
can't stand it you know it's it that's
you're it's a no-go for you but if you
can stand having a Twitter account you
can go to Twitter spaces and it's almost
like it's almost like an audio uh stage
so in other words and usually what Gabe
there's like seven to ten thousand
listeners in this space at night
um yeah I mean like it's one of those
um
yeah I would say probably it's one of
those seven to ten thousand people
listening but there's probably anywhere
from eight to ten people on the stage at
once that can talk and it's usually one
person talking at a time unless I go in
there like when I go in there I'll say
something and like all the right Wingers
turn their mic so like you [__]
because I just I literally when I came
in last night Mario and um Solomon were
like oh Tony's here oh [__] because I
totally raised the temperature of the
room like they're like they're all you
know talking like this and then I get in
there and [__] just I just piss them
off I mean it's just like I just come in
with bucking a flamethrower it's an
audio only chat room yeah
so it's like this but just audio yeah
yeah it's also I mean like it's as if
you're listening to the podcast right
you know like that but yeah there's also
you know it's and you can I think Mario
records them so you can go back and
listen yeah yeah you can they're like
six hours long they're very long uh and
sometimes you get people like uh live
partners in there right yeah life
Partners was in there last night might
spill the tea on stuff he was spilling
the tea on rooting we're gonna get to
that yeah and so so what I was saying
before was like you know what we were
talking about yesterday was the idea
that like if you ever make fun of Nazis
or fascists or pedophiles or groups or
whatever like you know you would you
would hope that Republicans would say
yes you are correct we should not defend
those people and that is uh a a an
egregious act that is terrible that is
uh horrific that is that is vile instead
these people get super triggered right
super upset about stuff and it's like
look
if you're trying to prove that you're
not this thing don't defend this group
of people right don't go and defend
instead of being like hey man Rudy
Giuliani that was really [__] gross
that's like we should believe the woman
and that's that's horrific and instead
they go nah nah Rudy is America's mayor
oh yeah that's all fake that's all
[__]
Tommy tub are real they're my white
supremacist them are Americans you know
I mean yeah they're American white
supremacists Tommy you dumb [__]
finish the end of the statement speaking
of white supremacists that's a great uh
lead in here to Andy Biggs Andy Biggs
trying to defend the uh Durham report
against uh McGovern watch this this is I
haven't seen this I just read a little
bit of the back and forth let's watch it
I I get where you're coming from but
let's also talk about the Durham report
that just came up yeah let's do that big
so so
and let's talk about this as what it is
yeah image of bills that deal with
Federal and local law enforcement so but
it didn't deal with it the way you
wanted so so now it's the January 6th
issue although I get it that's that's
all you got so go ahead hang your head
on that tell me that's not partisan all
right you guys made this
hang your hat on
that so McGovern is about to um
is about to burn Annie Biggs to the
ground uh here watch watch him Burn It
To The Ground uh because McGovern
operates in a space of I don't know
being Tethered to some sort of reality
here so watch how he just burns him down
and and listen Andy Biggs is no bobert
any big ex isn't a dumb [__]
like Lauren bobert or Margaret Taylor
green he's not a dumb Buck okay and it's
actually kind of scary that Andy Biggs
is on the side of fascism here because
Andy Biggs is not a dummy but watch
McGovern just absolutely undress him
here watch hey man watch McGovern's look
look at his the way he sits if you have
somebody coming after you and they're
just doing this
you know I mean they're not animated
they're not leaning forward they've got
your ass man
McGovern is excited that Andy Biggs
brought up the Durham report he's like I
knew you would and thank you so much oh
keep doing it dumb [__] keep
bringing this up and official hearings
let's get this [__] on the record so
watch watch what McGovern puts on the
record here last week
um I don't know whether you had an
advanced copy of the dorm report but I
think the Durham report was a colossal
waste of money but let me just point out
for the records that you brought it up
federal prosecutors have secured
convictions or confessions from Trump's
campaign manager Deputy campaign manager
fundraiser Chief strategist National
Security advisor two foreign policy
advisors his personal lawyer
Trump has been charged with 34 felony
the jury of his peers said that he he is
a sexual abuser special counselor
Mueller issue 25 indictments against
Russian Nationals who attempted to
undermine the 2016 election at the
orders of Russian President Vladimir
Putin and I did a cursory reading of the
Durham report online
um I don't see any indictments
a number of you were saying there'd be
multiple of diamonds I know did I miss
something were there indictments
okay so so basically basically
McGovern's like oh you want to bring up
the Durham report you stupid [__] I got
a whole list of [__] that I'm keep going
listen Republicans I'm I'm begging I'm
begging you keep bringing up the words
Durham report yeah at all costs anywhere
you can you are going to eat [__]
sandwiches for the next year and a half
if you keep talking about Hunter Biden
and [__] Durham report I hope you
keep it up because that is a losing
message America doesn't give a [__]
about that laptop and they don't give a
[__] about this report they don't care
they want their grocery prices down they
want [__] groceries on the shelves
they want their gas prices down which
are coming down they want to make sure
their [__] wages are increased they
want to make sure they don't go broke
because of a medical bill you dumb
[__] they don't care about
Hunter buying's laptop or derms report
they don't give one [__] well you also I
mean the other the other reason too is
because like you even even if we you
know for the hunter Biden stuff or the
Joe Biden stuff right you've got uh
you've got James Comer right the [__]
I swear to God I swear to God I swear to
God James Comer looks like Humpty Dumpty
okay Humpty Dumpty you all can fact
check me look at a comparison photo
James Comer looks like Ryan Humpty
Dumpty Kentucky Fried Comber can you get
can you can I'm gonna I'm gonna google
image it go ahead yeah I'm gonna check
this in real time so so make sure yeah
the idea and I and I really go into into
Comer and I have what was that that I'm
editing right now but the idea that
James Comer and Jim Jordan and all these
other Republicans are like oh man the
oversight committee we're really going
to root out you know waste fraud abuse
and we're gonna go after the Biden
Administration
okay well I hope that you actually have
some proof right and every single time
he goes into an interview and they ask
him so how about that evidence what is
your informant or your whistleblower say
well you'll you just have to wait and
see we'll just let you know like no one
no one if you were trying to expose this
bombshell investigation you would
[__] drop nuggets along the way for
people to follow the crumbs
but when you ask
James Comer hey what's the deal man you
got any new Spicy info for us and he's
like well uh we think it's unethical
it's not illegal we don't have evidence
our informant went missing The
Whistleblower is in the Spy business as
well like it's all this [__] they
don't have actual proof and it's years
the Durham report is a perfect example
we wasted I don't know six seven million
dollars whatever it was on the Durham
report and what did it reveal nothing
Obama didn't do anything wrong Hillary
Clinton didn't do anything wrong and all
the people that McGovern just listed off
there's like if there's smoke there's
fire right there and the last thing I'll
say is the idea that Republicans want to
say oh my God they colluded and this was
all a way to make Trump lose the
election except Trump won the election
and then you're also going to tell me
that Trump uh approved with with Barr
this investigation in Durham to expose
this this fraud and this this uh
conspiracy well it didn't expose
anything and no one was charged from it
there was nothing that came out of it so
it sounds like it was a waste okay so
here's your fact check there's uh
everyone can see on the screen this is
this is Congressman Q Anon
um Jim Comer that's him chicken fried
Comer he's from Kentucky Fried Comer
Kentucky he's from Kentucky
two quick points two quick points
I I personally know where Kentucky Fried
Comer's witness went
he is in a mail room with Tucker
Carlson's evidence about Hunter Biden's
laptop that got lost in the mail okay
that's where he's at the last picture
the last picture was not Humpty Dumpty
it was Comer this picture for the
audience this is Humpty Dumpty this is
not James Comer just to be clarified I'm
just saying I know they look a lot alike
I'm just saying there's a biopic
anyways go ahead Texas second point I
want to give huge props to McGovern
people always tell me Paul you should
run for Congress you should run
I could not do what McGovern is doing
there because I would be sitting there
this would be me where the indictments
at
come on Andy you said they'd be
indictments with the indictments you
know I mean I would be doing my best
Chris Rock imitation all the time oh my
god well you know
I should run for Congress and I'm like
what are you kidding me there's no way I
wouldn't last five minutes as much as I
say the word [__] it wouldn't last it
just wouldn't last hell I can't even
hardly stay on YouTube saying the word
[__] so I don't know what do you think
Gabe was that fact check correct do you
think we got the yeah I think it's
pretty clear they're the same person
I've got some additional photos uh okay
good for the what was that that'll show
that was that was just that was just my
my first initial search and I just
searched Jim Comer and both those images
came up no I mean that's that's what it
is like I I was I was looking through
footage and I was like he keeps making
these like raised eyebrow kind of
[__] and being like confused face
and then he's got like
you know how people joke around with uh
Charlie Kirk and we all make his face
smaller right like right his face Mar
and his head bigger like it's a bad Mr
Potato Head yeah that's James Comer just
naturally like right he his face is so
wide and so blocky that it looks weird
and the hairline looks weird and how it
lines up it just looks like a lot more
skin and less face and so when I kept
looking at the footage I was like man
what the [__] does he remind me of and
then
I was like ah yes Humpty Dumpty it's
[__] Humpty Dumpty
and you know if you get a picture of him
standing you're so right Gabe because
it's like that entire
thing oh yeah he just and then you got
the little chart of Kirk face in the
middle and it's like somebody push him
off the wall somebody pushing me off the
wall he looks like he looks like if you
were to draw a stick figure and put it
inside like a like a a barrel like a
whiskey barrel kind of thing like he
looks like uh like an Oompa or like you
know like the he reminds me kind of like
the girl in uh Willy Wonka who eats the
blueberry and then blows up right and
they roll her through the room like it's
you got that like like gravity they say
like they're like oh lower lower people
stack your piece there have a better
center of gravity I feel like for for
James Comer like one push like
like uh like Texas Paul said he would
[__] down off the great fall down the
hill and couldn't put him back together
again okay so yesterday we talked about
the Twitter Trend over the weekend
um the I hate boobs crowd
um and um there's some new
Revelations about uh the I hate boobs
crowd they think man you tell me if I'm
wrong they're really upset that the
Borat film
is part of this Rudy Giuliani evidence
that's been submitted to court
um well has it really been submitted to
court yes so in the front door no I'm
serious screenshots from the [__]
Borat though oh my God and I was and
they were pissed man they were in the
space last night they're in the Twitter
space they're like oh my God you
[__] it gotta be fake when
they're putting the Borat film I'm like
have you ever watched that part of the
film yeah if you watch that part of the
film
Sasha Baron Conan runs in the room
because he thinks Rudy Giuliani is gonna
get his dick out yeah he thinks he's
gonna get his dick out because he is
because this is not how you tuck in your
shirt folks yeah this is screenshot from
the film where Rudy Giuliani is claiming
he's tucking his shirt you do not tuck
in your shirt like this and the way and
the way that this plays out in the in
the movie right like Sasha bear Cohen
has a as a you know as a Saturday show
it we'll get knocked but she will
probably get knocked but the idea so the
he does an amazing job of don't do it
man don't do it I mean out of pointing
out don't show the clip no why no don't
get because you know you'll get a
copyright violation
[Laughter]
do you think I give a [__]
so basically but people who haven't seen
I can find a little bit I won't play the
sound whoever hasn't seen the movie
basically
they use his you know uh that actress in
the movie uh because it's not real
except these moments are real but as
them you know their characters they're
in another room that's off behind where
the bed was and they were doing an
interview right and she was very kind of
flirtatious and the whole goal was to
get him to reveal stuff
and you know she puts his her hand on
his leg and he's like oh okay and then
she's like oh you know I'd love to get
your contact info like why the [__] do
you need contact info
from this stuff but they have their
drinks right and they sit down on the
bed and she's bending over to go get
something meanwhile I'm just tucking
he might have I forget but uh he he he
says I was just tucking in my shirt it
was just a [__] tuck job nobody lays
on a bed flat no and then goes let me
just tuck in my pants no no one does
that no one does that the only reason
you [__] lay flat on a bed and you
put your hands in your pants is if
you're gonna pull out your little
whacker
Texas ball go ahead is that a tuck in a
shirt technically we have all reached in
like that but it was to grab our balls
or scratch our balls or do something
with our junk nobody tucks their shirt
in that way nobody he didn't go off to
the side to straighten his shirt out he
was elbow deep man I mean [__]
churning that [__]
young woman with a young woman literally
inches from him nobody reaches in grabs
the sack and nobody yeah that is not
tucking your shirt in also when you park
your shirt in right the idea is like I'm
only gonna what is this a French tuck
like I'm gonna tuck in the front of my
shirt in I'm talking all of my shirt in
so if I'm on the bed I'm like oh it's oh
it's clearly the front that's the
problem not the back okay well here it
is um this is the um this is the part in
the bedroom now I got it muted but you
see he's trying to take her microphone
off right yeah and he's he's sitting on
the bed oh yeah oh now watch great oh
Pat sir yeah baby yeah hey baby you want
to get on the bed with me
um yeah she's taking his microphone off
right and he's like oh yeah oh well
let's get way yeah let's uh let's get
way down in that junk let's get it oh
yeah and then you see
you see Sasha bear Conan as
um his character here coming in to try
to defuse the situation and the reason
why is because they actually thought
that he was gonna get his dick there was
a so they had behind they had interviews
that they did and they had um there was
that moment where he was actually
fearful of what was going to happen and
the second moment that he said in all of
the moments that he's filmed throughout
all the characters he's done and all the
situations he's been in he said the one
that was the craziest was when he was at
the rally and people knew who he was and
they all stormed and started beating on
the trailer they were in and so he was
actually afraid because they were like
holding the sister one where he sings
the song
is that the one where he goes on stage
and he sings the song yeah oh my God
that's such but people start with just
like oh that's Sasha Baron Cohen like
we're all being made fools of and they
all Start Spreading and he goes back to
his little trailer uh van and then he's
like there's behind the scenes footage
that they show and he talks about where
they're like holding the latch because
it's just one of those like little wagon
trailers that you like can change that
you might see on like a set or something
right and he's got like latching on for
dear life because if he doesn't these
people will [__] tear him from limb
to limb it's crazy because that film and
everyone you know even if you hate the
the idea you should at least go watch
parts of this film because it was done
during the pandemic yeah and there's one
point where Sasha Baron Conan during the
pandemic goes and he he he isolates
himself with two uh Trump supporters
that hate Clinton and their their
Partners their life Partners their
heterosexual life Partners they claim
right in this house and it's kind of
weird and he as the character bored he's
he's like questioning him about like uh
Clinton and what they believe and it's
it's wild [__] you gotta go watch some
of that film I mean even the interview
that Rudy does with this fake journalist
it's it's some wild stuff it's some wild
[__] can I can I address your audience
directly Tony yeah go ahead I love you
people if you haven't been reading the
comments they're talking about Rudy's
dirty trouser butter
I love you people so much they're the
funniest I love audience out there
they're the they are hilarious oh my God
dirty trouser butter I will use that
people I will use that in the future I
have never heard that term before but it
is now in my lexicon thank you you have
the best audience you guys you guys
really man those I don't know I mean
reading through the the lawsuit and
getting some summaries of like key
sections right right you hear him
uh how he wanted to be like Bill Clinton
right he would get a [__] on
speakerphone on speakerphone so it's not
just like holding the phone here which
would also be kind of weird if you're
like
yeah but the idea that you could then
hear others is that in the noise do you
think is that because we're gonna We may
hear audio of Rudy Giuliana she's got
like what does she have 36 000 emails I
well that's the thing and life Partners
listen there's a lot of salacious stuff
in this lawsuit right and and this this
this woman should have her truth told
um out in the open of how this
[__] took advantage of her and
let Parnes in the space last night this
is Lev's words now I'm not quoting
exactly but Lev was saying that Rudy
would do this where he would hire women
he would make them big promises to
impress them
um and the main goal was to be romantic
quote unquote and it was to have sex
with them and he would he would do
things like put Donald Trump on
speakerphone and gather all the the
girls in the room or the women in the
room as lead put it to impress them and
Lev was in the room several times when
he would do this now the thing that gets
me the most and I think um politically
because every listen everyone knows
[__] Rudy is a drunk they know he's a
[__] perv they know he's a scumbag we
know this by now we didn't used to know
it but we know it now and Levy even
admits that hey Rudy now is not the Rudy
five years ago it's not the Rudy 10
years ago he's a different guy now and
it's because of trump and having him in
his orbit and getting him more and more
in this corruption mode but here's the
thing
is that life Partners said because while
we're in the room
while Parnes is speaking about Rudy and
some saw it as disparagement but I saw
it as Leb just telling the [__] truth
about Rudy is that on MSNBC the lawyer
of this woman was alleging that Trump
and Rudy were plotting to sell pardons
for two million dollars a piece and
split that two million bucks 50 50.
which I'm no [__] lawyer I'm not a
United States Attorney but to me that
seems illegal as [__] now if that's true
if that's true the lawyer also suggested
that Leb Partners was a party to some of
these conversation meaning he was in the
room when some of these conversations
about the pardons happen now in the room
at real time okay this is real time let
Parnes is asked buy one of the co-hosts
hey did you ever hear any talk about
Donald Trump and regioni selling Pardons
and Le Partners didn't go as far to say
that they were talking about money but
Donald Trump and Rudy Giuliani were
definitely plotting
to give people Pardons and who they were
going to give pardons to now again Lev
did not say that he had any evidence or
any or he knew of any money being talked
about but he knew Trump and Rudy
Giuliani yeah were talking but also if
he did if he did know and he was privy
to those conversations that wouldn't be
something he would reveal on his space I
mean isn't he on I wouldn't think so
house arrest right now well I mean he's
he's uh he's still on his supervised
release I believe
um but also like if there is his
investigation right there's his lawsuit
and he might be a party that they've
spoken to to say hey
we have these allegations and we want
you to corroborate these things right
like I'm sure that in a space if he did
know
certain information that he'd be like ah
I got to be careful what I can say here
because I don't want to like spill the
beans on something or ruin it again they
were all pissed off because when Lev
came in the room they were trying to end
the space right and Leb said hey
everyone's talking about this Durham
report which is kind of [__] what
you're missing is all this the Rudy
lawsuit that is dry of course and and he
said I haven't read it yet but I I know
that it's happening and the room kind of
exploded and they accused him of
bringing it up and then Lev Lev is a
good character witness for Rudy because
Le Parnes was at Rudy's side doing a lot
I mean we've been in spaces before where
he's talked about he's like I was there
with him I was the one who connected him
with this person I was the one who was
literally next to his side at the house
in this country you know what's crazy is
he says he claimed last night that not
only did he meet this woman he met This
Woman's mother and Reed Giuliani would
take this woman and her mother all
around the world and I don't know if
that's if it's something like that but
Lev also said that they went to her
mother's house
they went to her mother's house and that
um lead Partners I believe he claimed
last night that he also he personally
dropped off this woman who is alleging
this lawsuit at Rudy giuliani's Hotel
so again does that mean anything is
there any evidence there of anything no
but what it does tell me is that lead
Parnes is a good character witness and I
would not be surprised if the lead
partnes is actually subpoenaed in this
case to to give his to give his account
of what happened in these videos and if
there's tapes of this maybe it'll
refresh Lev's memory of exactly what
happened the before and after in the in
the breakdown of what this
what this actually shows there's a part
in here and I just want to make sure I
get the number right
um there's a part in here that talks
about I believe it's like 36 38 000
emails and inside those emails
if I can find okay here we go
um all right so inside the emails there
are a lot of different parties that are
involved right
um okay there's the weird texts and the
pardons okay it's uh Ivanka Don Jr
um uh Lev parnis so basically she got
access to his email on her computer from
what I remember right and now uh she has
all of these emails and all of these
people are now
uh connected in different ways right
especially if she was like oh yeah if
anyone on in those spaces or anyone on
the rights like oh these are a bunch of
BS accusations no proof it's like dude
36 000 emails
there's gonna be something in there like
it's not gonna be all 36 000 but there's
probably a handful 30
000 emails okay so the other thing that
LE partner said about these emails and
and I'll let you go Texas Paul on on on
on your thought here it because I think
this is important for everyone to hear
lepparn has claimed in the room last
night that this was one of the things
Rudy would do when he would hire these
women is he would give them full access
to his text messages to his emails and
the reason why is because he wanted to
read that he was getting emails from all
these powerful people talking about all
these important things and it was him
giving bragging rights to kind of
impress impress these women because I
mean he's not that impressive otherwise
you watched him you know get his uh his
trouser butter going
um so
so he's not that impressive anyways so
so Leb was saying that the reason why he
gives access to some of these people who
work for him the emails and the text
messages and all that [__] and what what
he encourages them to record him because
for prosperity and he thinks he's the
good guy Texas Paul so what was your
thought there
that Jack Smith now owns Rudy Giuliani
and and by Absentia from this case not
because of this case Rudy Giuliani has
been making statements in other cases
that he is financially destitute that
he's broke right that he can't afford to
produce evidence because he's broke
um
he's been lying in this case proves he's
been like this woman has detailed
knowledge about his finances about his
business
you the the two parts about bringing a
lawsuit like this is one can you prove
it
and two can they pay
can they can you get anything from this
lawyers don't work for free folks
lawyers need their Subway sandwiches
just like everybody else
this case did not come to court just out
of the Goodwill of let's show the
country what a bad person this guy is
and save the country no they want to get
paid
and this that alone right there proves
to me did you the Rudy Julia giuliani's
ass is in a sling because he has been
making false Financial claims in other
cases Texas Paul you say he's in the
sling is it like a sex sling or is it
like a I'm just I'm just wondering I'm
just like hey one one of the things one
of the things in this that alleged in
this in this case the one of the
weirdest [__] things and of course
it's from Rudy Giuliani and Republicans
and someone that's close to Trump people
who claim the Democrats are the demons
and bloodsucking cabal and save the
children all this [__] part of the claim
in this lawsuit is that he would like to
pretend that she was his daughter when
they when they were performing sexual
acts on each other this is [__] weird
and he would introduce her as his
daughter sometimes even it's [__]
weird man these I'm telling you it's all
projection folks if that shit's true
it's all projects
I have some breaking news kind of
related kind of not is this relative
Hardy is sanctity of marriage
uh have it ready here we go
[Music]
uh-oh we have some breaking news as it
pertains to Lauren bobert and Jason
bobert this [__] and zoomed correctly
uh-oh she's no longer wearing a wedding
ring uh oh yeah but as we scroll down
right you might say oh that's not so
weird no people don't wear the wedding
ring all the time however
oh so
um Lauren bobert goes in the way of
Marjorie Taylor green she's getting a
divorce
um hmm looks like there's a docket
number below stands for domestic
relations and pertains to divorce uh
dissolution of the civil union legal
separation and uh imbality of the
marriage
it looks like it looks like
to me that there's a filing of divorce
now that doesn't mean they are divorced
that just right reverse proceedings are
are happening
um now is this the same guy I just want
to know since we're talking about weird
sex acts uh and sex slings and acting
like young women uh are your daughter
when you're performing sex is this the
same guy is this the Jason bobert that
took his wiener out or was he tucking in
his shirt at the bowling alley no he was
he he literally just like whipped out a
little bit and said uh literally whipped
it out and showed off his tattoo right
oh I didn't need to know that he has a
[__] spider tattoo on his dick wait
wait but now I know that wait wait wait
say wait
a second wait a second
you're telling me you're telling me
Jason bobert Lauren bobert's now
separated husband has a tattoo of a
spider on his dick
the victims the underage girls they said
they were coming on to him because he's
such a hunky hunk and they wanted to see
they heard that he had a tattoo on his
dick
and they wanted to see it so she
attacked them and said my husband didn't
really do nothing wrong he was just
showing him a tattoo wait and that's way
and that's before they even got married
wait Lauren both Lauren opal was one of
the people that were there as witness to
said
TP and and said you know what and I've
joked about this before on the show but
she saw him and was like I'm gonna marry
that man
that's exactly I don't have his babies
and it's like after this happened she
those are her words those are her words
she said that when she saw this in her
whole interaction she said I better nail
this down because you know women want my
hunky hunk okay I mean they just I I
wanna I wanna tell a short story here
um because I don't have it I don't know
it kind of brings more I don't know
maybe the story about her and Ted Cruz
is true it could be well that may be why
they're getting divorced listen I don't
have a tattoo I don't have tattoos
but I have joked before I had a joke
before that I would probably get a if I
was gonna get a tattoo if I was gonna
pay a lot of money for one I'd get a
really
um nice realistic rendition of a rubber
chicken on the inside of my thigh where
the beak would hang down to my knee and
the reason why is because then I could
pull up my shorts is I could say I have
a [__] that hangs to my knees and I
could see you're telling me and the
reason why I say this is because the
original I'm just I'm just okay so uh
it's a joke it's a joke but I'm telling
you the reason why the reason why Jason
bobert put a tattoo of a spider on his
dick so he could whip his dick out and
say I got a spider on my dick is that
are that is that I don't know I don't I
mean I worked I worked with a there was
a guy in sales that I used to work with
back when I was at a startup in SF and
we were in the in the break room and in
the kitchen he goes he goes he goes no
it is fine it's fine he goes he goes uh
I got your name on my ass and I was like
what and he goes yeah man I got your
name on my ass and I was like I why is
mine why is Gabe's why is the name Gabe
on your ass and he goes I mean I
literally have your name on my ass and I
was like what are you talking about here
I'll show you and I go no that's fine
you don't need to show me he goes no no
no no
and it said your name on my ass
and I was like what when did you get
that he was like I was drunk one night
but I'll tell you it's one hell of an
icebreaker and I was like Jesus Christ
well that's what I always thought if I
had a rubber chicken tattooed on the
inside of my thigh that was all the way
down to my knee I can say I got a [__]
that hangs to my knees and I could
show
ah it's a joke but I look at the chicken
choke yeah man you know
um what is a rubber chicken the sound of
a rubber chicken oh son of a [__]
yesterday it was the I hate boobs crowd
today Warren bobert entered the spider
verse oh [__] foreign
like well
we'll find out in the divorce movie oh
my God so learn about travels around the
country trying to tell us what the [__]
we're gonna do who the [__] you should
marry how the [__] it's sanctity of
marriage I think there's even a clip in
that thread from Patriot takes oh is it
Anki I hear where she talks about said
uh sanctity of marriage oh well let's
let's hear what she says about her
sanctity of her marriage I'm sure she
doesn't apply this rule to hers just
everyone else's let's listen
are you struggling in your marriage
begin to Speak Life
into your marriage
ladies
you are called
to something great oh my God in your
marriage
please make a spider reference power
that you have
in Christ for your marriage is unmatched
and if you start chasing Jesus with
everything that you have I promise you
your husband will chase you chasing
Jesus
that's what happened
she hooked up with issues
she went for you know the old Hispanic
you know got some got some Jesus love
and then her husband was chasing her
and Jesus she just said it right there
oh my God I mean Lauren bobert she's
like oh and the Holy Spirit this this
web of this yeah
you know situations here with Lauren
bobert but I mean man talk I mean you
know again these are the same people
you've got Margaret Taylor green who
says the superior gender is males and
women are here to work for you know men
which is interesting because it's like
well if you believe that then why are
you holding not and I don't believe this
but using their logic
if what uh Marjorie Taylor green says is
true and the fact that men are the
superior gender and and women are
supposed to be working and serving men
then why are women like Margie Taylor
green Lauren bobert and other people in
Congress again not my view but that's
their logic right here's the thing I
think anyone has the right to get
married yeah and everyone should be able
to get married I actually I don't I
don't rule off the table that people can
have more than one goddamn spouse it's
not my problem it's it's your deal right
that's your opinion that's what you want
that's how you want to live whatever the
[__] you want to do and ain't got [__]
to do with me and really honestly I
don't know who's the winner and loser
here in the bobert divorce whether it's
Jason or Lauren there's probably going
to be a lot of debate of who's the
winner and loser in that [__] divorce
but really honestly the thing that
pisses me off the most is when these
[__] run around telling other
people what the [__] they're gonna do
how they're gonna do it tell you how to
live your [__] life what you can you
gotta follow Jesus you got to put G
Jesus in your marriage Jesus this Jesus
that marriage this marriage that can't
have marriage if you don't want marriage
I I'm going to dictate who can and can't
get married these [__] can't
even stay married so [__] them and
really honestly [__] her because you
know she's the she's the manual of power
here not Jason bobert Jason bobert his
best stick that he's got in his entire
life is to have a spider on his dick so
he can show underage girls in a bowling
alley his [__] wiener and then a
court someone who happens to be
on a [__] recruiting website to get
recruited to be a congresswoman gets
elected and now she's running around the
country telling everyone else what
marriage is and what it isn't when she
can't even keep her own so I that's what
I'm [__] sick of is these people
telling other people what the [__] they
can and can't do when they don't even
hear to their own [__] rules so if
you spare me the [__] Lauren bobert
and spare me the [__] the nonsense
and the theater when you're standing up
talking about Jesus and God and marriage
and God will save you and Jesus saying
get the [__] out of here you don't
believe any of that [__] she's a [__]
phony she's a goddamn fascist and she's
a piece of [__] bottom line
for Jesus and Jesus is not her pool boy
Jesus is it's documented he's a
construction worker he works outside
with that shirt off
you know got the rip going on nice tan
and Lauren bobert couldn't resist old
Jesus I'm telling you that's what
happened and then her husband found out
and she said it right there in
confession on at the church in Rifle
Colorado just said it right there her
husband found out was chasing her and
Jesus and right the rest of History he's
filing for divorce is it a threesome if
Jesus is in the threesome I don't know
did you ever so when I was just asking
when I you know that actually when you
were whoa whoa whoa whoa that's a weird
transition I'm like Jesus
you're like when I was a kid I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna say that because of
the train because of the the training
yeah yeah
and the Holy Spirit is that how you is
that the how you do the Father's son
that's three that's the that what it
what what I don't I don't know what that
means what does that mean why I don't
know uh it's I don't know it seems a bit
shocking
what I will say is when I was a kid oh
God and I'll transition it into this
she's when I was a kid I went to
Catholic grade school yeah and when we
had our like you know uh we had a couple
dances like during the year right
got it and the teachers were the
chaperones right and the teachers I'm
waiting to see where this is and
whenever whenever you got too close for
comfort right too close you know with
your your dancing partner or whoever oh
I see okay they would say leave room for
Jesus leave room for Jesus so now now
I'm thinking now you you saying like
this whole threesome you guys both
talking about so I'm like oh maybe five
so maybe five some but maybe this whole
thing about leave room for Jesus was
because Jesus or Jesus whoever wanted to
be involved with the fun right and maybe
that's what they were saying the whole
time
can I ask you a question in all of your
education there and all of your
upbringing did anybody ever refer to the
Holy Trinity as the shocker
like Tony just did
what
does that mean what does that mean I was
trying to do I was trying to do it three
one two three most of my adult life
at this moment right now so I want to
thank Tony for introducing gutter
a new gutter a new way to look at that
uh
oh son of a [__] talk about
um
um Jesus and Weirdos I don't know I'm
trying to transition around I mean a
real
coming to Christ a moment right right
with Ron DeSantis so we watch we saw the
uh the picture around this let me see if
I can can you pull up the picture of him
can you pull up that picture where he's
uh pull the picture up and then I'm
gonna find the uh the video here
um we we showed this picture the other
day but honestly the um I'm laughing so
hard I'm crying
this is a good show today for [__]
sure it's one to remember
um I'm not um disappointing here so uh
let's see here we're going to hell
I've got a one-way ticket there if
there's anything to be said it's that
people will at least leave satisfied
right well that's true I mean if they
watch the show today and and they're not
having fun well [__] you go go somewhere
else where it's boring go listen NPR or
some dumb [__] you know what I mean I
mean if you're not if you're not coming
here to get delivered the news and the
commentary that you need
um and and your idea is that oh well
Tony's Tony's just gonna give us the
cold hard facts it's not going to have
any kind of
salacious step involved well you're
you're
um way out of Step here okay where
where's this okay here's the picture I
sent it to you okay all right here's the
picture that we showed Oh [__] [__]
okay here's the picture of Rhonda santis
trying to not act weird in Iowa totally
totally totally normal thing that humans
do is they definitely laugh like this if
you if you were a non-human trying to
pretend to be a human this is definitely
what you would be doing okay question if
if he laughed like this and we'll watch
the video in a moment would you ever try
to stick something in his mouth like
like a pretzel or like a hot dog he's
there
[__] are all in the gutter
you're gonna get the chat going now with
[__] that he can go in his mouth I'm
just saying when you open your mouth
that wide right and you're like it's
like I mean you're just inviting someone
to stick a corn cob in it right a corn
cob huh well he's in Iowa right right
well okay so here is the someone pulled
the actual video here
um so that's the picture and believe it
or not the [__] video is way worse
than the picture it's way worse I love
what Rick Wilson said about this he's
like cue human emotion number 17.
it's like he's an AI robot no we were
listen we were talking yesterday and I
was talking about men in black and the
fact that on Men In Black you know they
have aliens in human suits that really
feels like what Rhonda Santos is is just
an alien in human suits humanoids now
I'm gonna turn it up here because the
audio does it for me
but here is Ron DeSantis trying to not
act weird when he's trying to human
laugh and doing his best of what humans
do when they laugh let's take a listen
that was nice how much is that
[Laughter]
nice nice why is it that funny
it reminds me of [__] uh of uh of oh
my God I'm looking at his name
um Sideshow Bob right yeah
right he's like
like it's man God damn
I got a weird laugh a lot of people make
fun of my laugh yeah isn't that weird
though my whole well my whole life it's
not awkward my whole my mind I don't
just be like
like like when someone says something
and it's not funny
and I don't know if like the guy behind
him is the puppet master and he pushed
the laugh button on accident you know
what I don't think it was a it was a it
was a button I think it's a drawstring
right wow
I'll show it again here on mute the
hands though the hands just kill me man
well watch the guy behind me
oh
yep it's almost like that guy's the
Rhonda Santa's ventriloquist look at
that [__] it's [__] creepy right he
laughed so hard he almost takes a bite
out of the woman that's the left of her
right I don't know she has to kind of
like whoa whoa whoa whoa and the guy in
front's like what did I say that was so
funny I wasn't trying
tell me you watch this and you can't
imagine that guy three finger and some
pudding
oh God damn you [__] oh man is
it two hours up yet no yeah you got 12
minutes oh [__] we gotta talk about more
three fingering for 12 minutes okay
um let's go to another story Gabe
Sanchez you've done some videos on
Patriot front and I find it funny
that um these [__] right Wingers on
on Twitter mainly and it's the internet
in general yeah yeah especially these
deep dark parts of the web picture front
Goes to Washington DC and they can't let
this go that that supposedly these
[__] Patriot front
people these [__] white weirdos these
incels
are somehow feds now I'm not saying that
some of them aren't cops I would
actually bet that some of them are
probably Law Enforcement Officers that's
one reason why they're wearing the
Whitey tighties over their face so no
one knows who they are so they don't get
fired from their [__] job I mean I
actually have footage from DC if you
want to watch it oh do you really okay
yeah is this is this the one you said oh
I hope you got the guy I hope you got
the guy okay we'll play that video as
well yeah well boy this is live this is
live footage from DC let's see what
these Patriot front guys are about let's
listen we claim America has anyone seen
the U-Haul trucks I think I left my
white mask in there never mind guys I'm
just gonna use my tighty whities my mom
packed us some snacks in case we get
hungry oh [__] my bad yeah that's right
mask on gotta protect your identities I
will wear a mask for coven we are white
nationalists not the FBI guys I got my
shield in case any antiva try to come at
us no a bunch of teams didn't scare us
off earlier who told you that no no that
was last time in Philly and that was
like a mob of like like 12 teens I just
bought my khakis on Black Friday at
Walmart it was a BOGO does anyone know
when the rental trucks are coming back
to pick us up they wouldn't leave us
behind right right hey Mom can you come
pick me up my friends left me again yeah
I have your cookware and so uh there's
live there
that's a good one man that's a good one
that's a good one you know I couldn't
help but think when I saw this it like
you know I'm you know it's difficult to
find a good laundry service but are you
telling me none of them could get their
hoods back [__]
we'll cut bigger holes and they're like
all right let's let's not wear the hoods
no we gotta wear the hoods we're wearing
the goddamn hoods well you ain't worried
him I'm going home damn it
my wife worked all day on these hoods
and then he tries to Open the Eyes
[Laughter]
God damn it ah you [__] I really hope
you all have the video of that guy that
was riding around on the bike that was
this is my new freaking hero Tony oh
yeah
especially the last comment the last is
the best these people can't stop telling
on themselves because like the idea that
some of these Patriot fronts are actual
Law Enforcement Officers which I'm not
saying they are they are yeah frankly
there's probably some of them that are
but yeah we we we know who a lot of them
are because they were arrested in Idaho
and they were mug shot they have mug
shots of these people we know who some
of them are it's not [__] complicated
to know that these people aren't federal
law enforcement officers it's not you
[__] boneheads they arrested them in
Idaho and they booked them you dummies
um what's this this one here that you're
that you sent me so that's the clip he
actually got featured the guy the red
bike guy Joe flood uh was what's his
name Joe flood Joe featured on Rachel
Maddow oh [__] I'm gonna follow this guy
yeah God damn okay so
um
let's pull this up here this is on
Rachel Mano show uh of the of red joe
joe flood is his name yeah let's let's
listen masks and they have their little
Shields and they held upside down
American flags once again the white
supremacist glee club that calls itself
Patriot front
um they marched this weekend in DC
trying to intimidate people chancing
chanting racist slogans so scary by the
way and a local DC man named Joe flood
heard that they were out there heard
that that was happening when he heard
that they were out there in his City he
hopped on a bike and he went to go try
to find them on the National Mall you
can see Mr flood there there he is he's
right here with the backpack and the red
hey can you follow him and message him
see if he'll come on the show yeah yeah
that would be fantastic maybe we'll get
maybe we'll get him on the show tomorrow
tell him we're playing a clip of him on
The Rachel Maddow Show right now and see
if he'll come on tomorrow and and give
us his perspective on the ground there
for what he saw let's listen to the rest
of the report here on the right he's got
the red bike standing near the group Mr
flood told us when he found them today
he felt suddenly that it was his duty to
say something
so he did
all right simply no time
reclaim your return
Mr Flynn told this quote this guy was
giving the speech he kept having to stop
and pull it out of his pocket and then
start reading it again so every time he
stopped I would yell at him and say he
was boring yeah so there's there's
Rachel's Meadows report on a hero on a
hero who doesn't wear a cape because not
all of them wear capes some of them
right I didn't wear backpacks she didn't
show the best line there they're the
best line by far was when he yells
because the guy's got the funky ass
mustache and [__] going on she he yells
at him you look like Custer's
illegitimate child
I don't know I don't think I think the
reclaim your virginity yeah I mean he I
mean it's funny I mean a lot of the I
mean obviously a lot of these uh these
white supremacists are super triggered
they get very in their fields if you
call them bad names you know we've seen
it again and again people they don't
like loud noises they don't like
whistles they're very fragile people
yell at them it's it it hurts their
sensitivity you know what I mean it's
you know when you when you call them a
mean name Like A Nazi or a fascist or a
racist or a bigot or a sexy story it is
really weird when we call them Nazis and
fascists they're like oh we're not the
actual Nazis in fascist we launched
Texas ball there I'll be back in a
second yeah but again I mean it goes
back to what you said yesterday like if
you're getting upset at us making fun of
Nazis
that says a lot about your preference to
likey Nazi right well the other thing
too is when they say when they're like
when we're like hey they're fascists or
not she's like no they're not Nazi look
listen they're not Nazi they're not
really
users
you're the first person to come to their
defense and be like oh no no those guys
are feds
here's a video going around the internet
and they're using this as evidence that
I don't I don't know why I I don't again
it's kind of The Narrative of Hillary
Clinton colluded with Russia so she
would lose the election and Donald Trump
would win or that antifa went to the
capital to overthrow the government and
make sure that Joe Biden wasn't
certified as president it doesn't make
any sense why Patriot front would be
feds and Nazis like it's really weird
stuff that they're claiming the cops
have you thought about how Patriot front
has to feel about all this I mean it's
your side that thinks you suck so bad
they do because I've got to pretend
you're the other side I mean no no
they're not the real ones these are the
wannabes they're they're the they're the
they really try so hard to be the the
white supremacist but those are actually
feds it's like we're really premises
like the real ones exactly that's I
really don't want to get into the mind
of Like A Nazi or white supremacist but
can you imagine your entire identity is
to try to be a white supremacist a white
nationalist and a Nazi and the people
the people who are who are supposedly on
your side that are the Nazis are like no
you're feds and like yeah so but we're
Nazis too like I don't get the idea the
idea that you you're that white
supremacist Patriot front get trolled so
hard that the only way for other white
supremacists to feel good about it yes
they are a nazi-ish on Facebook says
they are nazi-ish with the idea that
your own white supremacists people that
you align with like ideology wise you
know mentality every all of your beliefs
you align with white supremacists you
say yes I am like you you know the fact
that you have your fellow white
supremacists then going online and be
like no no these guys have been trolled
they're so such a [__] joke they're
pathetic they're not real Nazis because
real Nazis would be like we know what
real Nazis are trust me we know what
they really are but here's their
evidence so upset and they're like oh no
no that's not fair that's not fair you
guys are called we're real Nazis and
it's like
the turd right oh my God
okay so here's their evidence this video
is going around right wing on Twitter on
all on social media this is their
evidence I'm not [__] you this is
the evidence that they're getting that
that Patriot front is a false flag it's
all feds it's all cooked up by the left
to make people believe that there's
actual Nazis when there's like real
Nazis in Ohio protesting There's real
Nazis in in Florida protesting outside
Disney with swastikas and they're not
hiding it they're actually saying yeah
we're Nazis but they think Patriot front
somehow is some sort of [__] psyop
from the government false Flagship but
this is their evidence watch this [__]
it's it's weird that this is their
evidence
videos
you're video saving us that's not
acceptable this is the public place your
video you're trying to get us in trouble
sir
go find one I'm deleting the video no
you're not gonna touch my phone you're
not taking a video of us
yeah I know you do
so give me my phone I'm deleting this is
their evidence then he's a Fed because
he doesn't want to be recognized he
doesn't want to be on camera this guy is
filming him because that's why they're
covering their faces because they don't
want to be recognized and these people
think that this is evidence of being a
Fed literally that's what they're saying
they're like oh this is clear evidence
you see how he said this is unacceptable
no one says that besides a fed I'm like
what the [__] are you talking about
because they use the word unacceptable
yeah get the [__] out of here man that's
ridiculous I'm very I'm very lost as to
why that makes him a Fed I don't know
but let me show you something I don't
know we know who these people are here's
their mug shots from Idaho okay man look
at these [__] Alpha Cooks I mean with
their [__] names okay look there's
their names there's who they are these
people were arrested in Idaho I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna lie oh the guy in
the lower left man I mean that's right
there you know that that that right
there that's your that's your Colonel
Sanders [__] Custer wannabe he
that's a guy who has to cover up his
chin but these are feds these are all
feds by the way but I will say this
there's a few people in here that I have
to be like it kind of looks like this is
an evolutionary chart from like homo sit
like homo well here's here's the other
one this guy right here look at these
guys can you imagine like the argument
after these marches when they're back to
the rental vans they're like yeah well
we're gonna go over and stop at the
McDonald's over on I-90 and they're like
no man I want to go
man we said we went to McDonald's last
time and I didn't know man
we're going to McDonald's because I like
the flurries over there no man I want to
go to Wendy's and get a frosty this time
man
just like imagining all of them uh
arguing in in the back of a truck while
it's moving and complaining about where
they're gonna go eat
you know they're like oh man we know we
got to go to we got to go to [__]
Jack In The Box and we gotta go to this
place we gotta go to that place and it's
like would you [__] pipe down you
either shut up now or I'm turning the
van around right I wanna I wanna and you
know there's one guy that's like no I
want pizza and then another guy's like
you can't have pizza cause you fart too
much and I ain't riding in the back of
this band if you're eating pizza
here's here's the here's the interaction
on on the uh underneath of this thread
where I showed these pictures that this
person says so which of these are feds
and of course showing all these mug
shots and this person says is that the
batch
from Idaho and this is the response
is is potato
oh my God I can't tell you how exciting
Today's Show is and if you weren't here
for today's show you [__] you you missed
out man you missed out Today's show was
one of the best I think we've ever done
one of the best it actually out of one
of the three one of the three best yeah
probably ever the whole show was a bit
of a shocker I didn't see it
that's fine that's fine I think I may go
have some Neapolitan um ice cream after
this you know you got the pink you got
the the stink hey you know what you do
yeah I'm gonna go have some pudding I'm
gonna go laugh maniacally and you know
use the correct three fingers when
you're I know I know am I the only one
that's going to get tacos after this I
mean really come on yeah
me and Jesus are going to go have some
tacos and talk about this whole bobert
thing that's what we're gonna do that's
good that's great everyone I'll make
sure to make sure to go to
realtexaspall.com the Link's down there
in the bio uh go follow Texas Pawn all
the social media platforms and don't
forget he does his show on Sunday here
on YouTube so go to realtexaspaul.com
again the link is down in the bio and
follow Texas Paul there and of course
come here on every Tuesday where it's a
shocker of a show uh every every tackle
I mean it really puts a new meaning to
shock jock radio right well it does it
does so don't forget to subscribe here
on the Shocker show the Tony Michaels
podcast uh so you don't miss a single
shocking episode
um when we uh really dig three fingers
deep into every pudding gut that there
is uh with the Trinity uh no matter what
the breaking news is subscribe here on
YouTube Jesus Christ they're definitely
gonna ban us
um follow us on Twitter go follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels by download
every single episode and if you're
downloading you're listening to the
audio version listen you gotta come
watch the show every once in a while too
especially on Tuesdays you're not going
to want to miss it if you're if you're
not coming to this show right baby
come ones come all
um you know where else you can come and
watch it you can go to Facebook if you
still have Facebook account go to at the
Tony Michaels you can watch it live or
the replay there it'll shock you trust
me stay out of the way though I want to
give a shout out on Twitch
um Shadow woman seven has been gifting
Subs over there oh yeah thank you so
much uh Shadow woman seven uh for for
the um for the for the gifting of Subs
over there and if you don't know this
already if you are an Amazon subscriber
you can actually get one free
subscription over on Twitch just link
your Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account here's how you do it you go to
the Tony michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com just scroll down just a bit
the link is right there it says link
Amazon and twitch you can link those
account give us your one free
subscription and we will get a couple
bucks of Jeff bezos's penis rocket money
you know not to be confused by his other
money but we get a few bucks of his uh
his rocket money go link your Amazon
account to your Twitch account we
appreciate all the followers over there
it's free to follow too if you don't
have a Prime account you can still
follow over there oh boy I don't know if
we can top this show tomorrow but we're
gonna try we're gonna try I promise same
time same place
Surf's Up [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em [__]
[__] them
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn headass Beacon